like I was saying a second ago I'm you
seemed I saw you at the party last night
you seemed very happy it's probably cuz
the movies awesome yeah that's exactly
why it was it was it was also nice to
you know sharing my first film with my
family they'd you know never never seen
anything like that before
and to see my face on the screen and you
know my mom was definitely shedding a
few tears and there that's awesome but
as I said a second here let me start by
saying I think the movies fantastic you
guys did great work one of the things is
that I don't think no matter what Robert
or James or anyone told you going in you
can't really know what it's gonna
finally look like until you get to that
theater and see it yes so what the hell
is it like seeing it for the first time
because the visual effects are so insane
yeah I mean when I screened it like a
week ago I'd just like you said I had no
idea what to expect because the world is
just so much bigger than then you could
even put it on paper right and it was
mind-blowing that they did the most
incredible job with all of the all the
visual effects it is so delicious to
watch it's like it's quite incredible in
it and and and i saw fight choreography
that I've that I've never seen in any
movies before they were it's it was very
original and it's it's beautiful if you
it really take as well as the audience
member it really takes you out of
reality and you believe that you were in
that world for two hours yeah just to
see you know obviously we did so much
incredible we saw a lot of incredible
work being done on set but then to see
what what a you know was able to create
after you know they you know everything
that they're looking at is just
reference so they have everything as
referenced in there I will just build
these it's insanely expansive you know
world building you know
milazzo mm-hmm mm-hmm
I mean you know just to piggyback on the
references it's just how much detail
they they had beforehand going into it
just gave us a good idea as to what does
it look like but you know nothing could
really prepare you for like that type of
world and it's just how crystal clear
and then and how it's just wonderful the
effects were in the movie one of the
things is I'm not the biggest fan of 3d
but the 3d in this is exceptional
yeah talk a little bit about why you
need to see this in 3d well if you if
you if you get headaches like me in 3d
you can actually see this movie because
it was shot in 3d it's not converted
into 3d and it's yeah it it's more it's
it's less about it always coming out at
you it's more kind of like you're the
audience members put into the screen
yeah it's really the only way to see it
you'll be able to see the scope and
scale much better you know with that
those extra you know inches on the
screen and then that you know very
immersive 3d experience one of the
things I'm always curious about
memorable moments from filming for each
of you guys what's like the day or two
that you always remember from the shoot
the first time I saw my Hershel alley
walk through the gates of iron City was
the most amazing experience of my life
and then I guess when we were shooting
like we went out to some rock formation
oh yeah yeah and we were standing out
there for hours and it was red-hot like
for hours on end standing on a rock yeah
and I'll remember that yes it is -
there's too many moments - you know to
say I mean did I really enjoyed a lot of
the riding the motor the gyro bike or a
mono cycle of her a lot of people say
different different things of what it is
but we tried a lot of different ways of
how to figure out to make it look as
practical as possible and they ended up
bringing in
this processed trailer that was used in
like the most recent like Mission
Possible and Need for Speed films and
this processed trailer is the fastest of
its kind it can go up to 130 miles an
hour
now I wasn't going that fast but we were
going about you know 4550 miles an hour
and even just being in that feeling was
you know quite amazing and it looks so
cool on camera I mean well for me I'd
say the scenes we filmed playing motor
ball outside it was just so cool to see
all the skaters come come through and do
so many tricks and also it's just it
made iron city feel alive you know
there's so much just life going on well
they were filming the skating and then
also all the practical sets that they
had behind them just it was it was a
kind of like an image that you know
years fast-forward I still kind of have
in my mind that also the scene that we
filmed we were fighting I just um I had
a lot of fun doing it so yeah that was
cool individual customer the three of
you before I ran out of time I
definitely want to know what it's like
working with Roland Emmerich I'm very
curious about John John Leguizamo's
critical thinking and I heard there's
some sort of all the boys sequel thing
I'm making and I'm doing this completely
wrong I can't read sarcasm or joke but
talk like what's the status of that
what's going on um we are gonna start
shooting that very soon we don't have
where we're looking for a second love
interest and it's gonna be awesome
uh yeah yeah go ahead no okay thank you
yeah Roland Emmerich is is absolutely
incredible he he's another one of those
directors that just completely thrust
you into whatever world he wants to
create and I got to work with ed again
which was fun so it was uh I was ed was
this you know this very courageous
fighter pilot and I was his very
skittish scared rear gunner so it was
amazing being in like a group that was
you know so different to leader because
we were on full green-screen
totally experiencing you know you know
real replicas SPD fighter pilot plane
from you know the Battle of Midway so
that was really fun though
really fun yeah that's really cool yeah
there's me yet again a critical thank
you know we finished filming it you know
they're they're currently in
post-production editing editing the film
it's John's I believe it's a directorial
debut it's a it's a real-life story of
this neighborhood in Miami which is my
hometown and just the tale of these
Latino and black kids who go on to win
nationals and chess from like the
poorest of poorest of neighborhoods and
it's special to me just because I'm
playing a Dominican and I as an actor I
don't really get a lot of chances to
play my nationality and let alone a
story that's from where I'm from
specifically as well cool again I'm just
going to say great job Congrats and have
a fantastic day thank you
you